but what it did was now put me in this
place where I'm like I don't want to
hide at my next
job I would love to just move how I move
and have it be part of it because maybe
it'll add something to the story it
doesn't have to be about it my whole
life is not about Ms why can't she be a
normal person who happens to have MS who
is convicted of murder that's right
that's right people with Ms can be
[__] too oh you could you can murder
that's right I would love to play a
really complicated like not murder yeah
why not never done that actually no I
did in Big Sky um but yeah I think that
in the past couple of years I'm
like letting it go
accepting yeah cuz you know the shame
thing could be twofold it could also be
part of you going hey I just really
don't want to be recognized right now
which is you know in general people wear
a hat or they're just kind of like you
know sometimes I'm at the airport and
not that I get mobbed but sometimes I'm
just like tired I just we hat and
sunglass and just not and just disappear
so that's like you know I'm having a
tough time I you know I'm in a
wheelchair I'm tired I I don't want I
just don't want to [__] deal with it
yeah so you know maybe it's not all
shame like you know I can't do these
things and but I you
know it's not even about being famous I
I it's it's like I don't know I'm just
being honest you know it's because I I
in
my meeting other people that live with
MS and chronic
illness and you know what in general I
just feel like the more that I
am being more honest with myself about
my feelings and talking about these
things like sometimes you think the more
specific you
get the more like distant it's going to
be then people aren't going to
understand but I'm finding like the more
specific I get the more Universal it
actually is and everybody's everybody's
got I live with my shame and my [__] out
you see it and I that's where I'm
grateful for it because it's really
opened me up it I can't hide from it
people ask me about it and then we have
to have I had the most beautiful
exchange with a TSA guy the other day
really yeah where I was getting the
wheelchair through security and he was
like Meadow and I'm like yeah and he's
like what's going on and I'm like oh I
have MS is you know makes my life easier
through the airport this and that and
then we just started talking and he said
to me he's like you know I really
appreciate you opening up to me right
now he's like having nothing to do with
what you've done and what you do like
you're a really beautiful person like
and I and I just started crying I'm like
thank you for seeing me but without this
I don't know if we would have had that
conversation do you know what I mean
like I feel like it's cracked me open I
see what you're saying in a way yeah and
I think I try not to find like a
spiritual meaning in everything in life
cuz I think sometimes that can like make
it overwhelming life overwhelming
sometimes things just happen but I do
think that bigger things happen in our
lives as catalst for us to really grow
and I think that maybe there would have
been something else but without Ms in my
life I don't I don't know where I'd
be wow I would like a life without it
though sure I would at this point do you
talk to well first of all do you have
any friends or family who just get
really emotional all the time when
you're around my mom she no matter what
if you're having trouble walking she's
she loses it hysterical and what do you
say Mom what are you saying it's okay
it's okay do you ever cry with her
sometimes yeah sometimes I try not to I
try not to yeah yeah yeah it's mainly
with her what about with other people
who are dealing with Ms yeah are you an
advocate like are you talking to people
are you are you Christine Applegate's a
really good friend of mine yeah I was
just with her this
morning she you know we have this like
Beautiful Exchange we talk about where
she feels like I'm like her light but I
also have have experience but she also
gives me permission to be like this
[__] sucks CU she's not afraid to say
that and I she diagnosed a couple years
ago right and and she had she had it for
a while or is it something that she's
only had it for just start not sure I
think it just it like there were
symptoms that were coming on and you
know she she figured out fairly quickly
from what I understand yeah and she's
sort of like hey what what's going to
happen What go what happens first what's
the initial like did she ask you a lot
of questions like we did yeah we had an
initial conversation but like I'm not an
I live with it I'm not an expert it
affects all of us very differently but I
think what it helps is just to have
somebody that understands